this about to get hot in here I got
cheated on that's what it is I was like
that too it's not saying to do it I was
like oh I'm here as a launch pad that's
it ain't about me it's about you really
really hard to lose 45 pounds or I could
just gain a hundred and get the surgery
my kid wants to be in the NBA my son's
like no my teacher said I can be
anything I want me to grow son you're
not gonna grow up to be a tall black man
that's since day one I have a plan I
said I'm gonna try to get as good as I
can as fast as I can so people could pay
me to talk honest and I was so nervous
she said girl me your mother
I knew you was gay when I called you
eating a banana side way
we go big or we go to hell
you